[Applause]
as soon as william router was declared
president-elect
raila odinga supporters in a stronghold
kisumu reacted with anger
they believe this election was stolen
police fired tear gas to disperse them
we are not going to accept and move on
until release the president
is the president of the republic of
kenya
we cannot accept as president
this was the fifth time veteran
opposition leader odenga has run for the
top job and lost even though this time
he had the backing of outgoing leader
uhuru
people here in western kenya say they've
been marginalized for years since
independence from britain in 1963 kenya
has never had a president from this part
of the country they were hoping that
that's going to change that's why they
supported ryla odinga who they say is
one of him i want you to know on the
campaign trail odinga promised to help
kenyans struggling against the rising
cost of living as well as tackling
corruption and foreign debt
it was a tightly contested election and
some parts of the country are tense with
the electoral commission split and the
results likely to be challenged in court
exactly what will happen next year among
odiga supporters remains unclear
harumutasa al jazeera kisumu kenya